unsere Welt steht vor nie dagewesenen
Herausforderungen
wie können wir unsere Volkswirtschaften
stärken und dabei gleiche Chancen für
alle schaffen wie können wir eine
nachhaltige Welt für die kommenden
Generationen schaffen unsere Städte
schützen und neue Technologien gemeinsam
nutzen
die Menschheit hat schon immer gut
vorausgedacht und wir werden die
Probleme von morgen bewältigen
Ungleichheit Nachhaltigkeit
Urbanisierung die Kluft zwischen den
Geschlechtern und die demografische
Zeitbombe
[Musik]
die Welt verändert sich wir stehen heute
an der Schwelle zu einer vierten
industriellen Revolution die die Art und
Weise wie wir arbeiten wie wir leben und
sogar das was uns zu Menschen macht
verändern wird
es gibt eine Vielzahl von Technologien
die derzeit in fast jeder Branche zu
einer Transformation führen
diese Technologien umfassen künstliche
Intelligenz 3D Druck Robotik Big Data
und sogar Biowissenschaften
in Bezug auf Genetik und medizinische
Bildgebung werden all diese
Entwicklungen eine Vielzahl von
Veränderungen mit sich bringen
ich würde die vierte industrielle
Revolution eigentlich ganz ähnlich wie
die letzten beschreiben und zwar als
eine Technologie die zu massiven
Produktivität gewinnen führt
und massive Produktivitätsgewinne
bedeuten erhebliche Verbesserung der
Lebensqualität aller
[Musik]
die Welt hat bereits früher Revolutionen
erlebt die Mechanisierung dann die
Elektronik und schließlich die digitale
Revolution haben die Wirtschaft der Welt
tiefgreifend verändert aber die jetzige
Revolution könnte sie alle übertrumpfen
frühere Revolutionen könnte man als
industrielle Revolutionen bezeichnen
hier änderte sich die Art und Weise wie
man Dinge produzierte in Fabriken und
vor allem in der Schwerindustrie nun
sehen wir nicht nur eine Transformation
in der Industrie sondern auch im
Dienstleistungssektor durch die
Schaffung völlig neu Geschäftsmodelle
das Besondere an dieser Revolution ist
dass sie eine ganzen neue Art von Jobs
erfasst Jobs bei denen man bisher davon
ausging dass sie nur von Menschen
ausgeführt werden könnten doch nun
werden diese Tätigkeiten nicht mehr von
Menschen sondern von Maschinen gemacht
im Zentrum dieser Revolution steht die
künstliche Intelligenz die Fähigkeit von
Maschinen menschliche kognitive
Fähigkeiten zu erreichen und vielleicht
eines Tages zu übertreffen
[Musik]
die jetzige Revolution wird alles
verändern es wird verändern wie wir
leben oder wie wir miteinander umgehen
es wird Menschen in den Bereichen
vollständig ersetzen von denen wir
dachten es können nur von Menschen oder
einem menschlichen Verstand erledigt
werden
doch nun stellen wir plötzlich fest das
Algorithmen das für uns erledigen
wir stehen erst am Anfang der
künstlichen Intelligenz aber die
technologischen Möglichkeiten sind
endlos
schauen wir uns die vielen Vorteile von
künstlicher Intelligenz an zum Beispiel
autonome Autos oder autonome Fahrzeuge
können das Leben vieler Menschen
erleichtern gerade für ältere Menschen
die nicht mehr selber fahren können
diese sind nun nicht mehr in ihrem
Zuhause gefangen und sind nicht mehr
abhängig von anderen für den Transport
mit fahrerlosen Autos könnten sie ihren
Alltag
nachgehenden Einfluss auf die
Medikamentenentwicklung mit ihrer Hilfe
kann man schneller neue Medikamente
finden um Krankheiten zu heilen die
Computer sind in der Lage Daten zu
sortieren und zu verknüpfen die Menschen
sonst übersehen würden
insbesondere im Gesundheitswesen sind
die Vorteile des maschinellen Lernens in
der datenwissenschaft immens die Chancen
sind hoch sowohl sehr seltene als auch
allgemeine Krankheiten zu behandeln wenn
wir Krebs heilen wollen werden wir das
wahrscheinlich durch datenwissenschaft
erreichen
aber diese technologische Revolution hat
möglicherweise auch eine Schattenseite
die die Arbeitswelt wie wir sie kennen
tiefgreifend verändern könnte
eine technologische Revolution wird
definitiv Arbeitsplätze kosten und zwar
Arbeitsplätze in den Bereichen in denen
wir die größten technologischen
Fortschritte sehen ein gutes Beispiel
dafür ist der Güterverkehr wenn wir
selbst fahrende Lastwagen haben brauchen
wir in den USA keine 3,5 Millionen
Lkw-Fahrer mehr
wie können wir also an dieser Revolution
teilhaben wie können wir unsere
Produktivität steigern unsere Wirtschaft
vergrößern und neue Arbeitsplätze
schaffen
wir müssen sicherstellen dass all diese
Arbeitslosen Lkw-Fahrer neue Fähigkeiten
erlernen um andere Jobs auszuüben es
wird natürlich nicht sofort alle
betreffen aber wir müssen sicherstellen
dass wenn wir irgendwo 3,5 Millionen
Jobs abbauen an andere Stelle 3,5
Millionen neue Jobs schaffen das haben
wir schon einmal geschafft und ich hoffe
dass wir es wieder schaffen werden
aber was ist wenn das nicht passiert
Martin Ford ist ein softwareunternehmer
er hat einen Blick in unsere künftige
Wirtschaft geworfen und sieht eine Welt
in der möglicherweise Hunderte von
Millionen qualifizierter Arbeitskräfte
arbeitslos sind
wenn wir in die Zukunft blicken wird es
in unserer Wirtschaft eine große Anzahl
von Arbeitsplätzen geben die aufgrund
der Fortschritte in der künstlichen
Intelligenz nicht mehr benötigt werden
viele Berufe die wir uns heute
vorstellen können Künstler
Schriftsteller Musiker und viele andere
werden durch maschinelle Lernsysteme
ersetzt werden dadurch werden Millionen
von Jobs verschwinden wir müssen daher
jetzt schon anfangen uns Gedanken über
Lösungen zu machen um die Folgen dieser
Entwicklung abzufedern
[Musik]
Martin Ford ist ein software-unternehmer
der eine beängstigende Vision von der
Zukunft hat ist besser mit seinen
Bestseller Büchern steht er an der
Spitze einer Bewegung die sich über die
Technologie die Geschwindigkeit ihres
Wachstums und das immense Potenzial dass
sie hat die Welt zu verändern Sorgen
macht dieses Aufkommen von Maschinen die
durch künstliche Intelligenz angetrieben
werden haben das Potenzial hunderte
Millionen von Arbeitnehmern auf der
ganzen Welt zu entlassen diese Welt
steht kurz bevor aber Regierungen und
Unternehmen beginnen erst begreifen
geht es darum das Maschinen Computer und
intelligente Algorithmen im Laufe der
Zeit die menschliche Arbeit zunehmend
ersetzen werden es ist unvermeidlich
dass die Technologie eines Tages in der
Lage sein wird viele der Aufgaben die
heutzutage von Menschen erledigt werden
zu übernehmen
es wird Menschen aus dem Arbeitsmarkt
verdrängen für viele Menschen wird es
unmöglich sein sich darauf einzustellen
weil sie nicht die gleichen Fähigkeiten
wie Maschinen besitzen ich denke das
wird ein echtes Problem für unsere
Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft sein
[Musik]
diese Maschinen sind bereits unter uns
Algorithmen die Dinge wie Körpersprache
interpretieren können und in gewissen
Maße auf Emotionen reagieren und das hat
große Auswirkungen stellen Sie sich vor
was das zum Beispiel für die Werbung
bedeuten könnte wenn ein Algorithmus
genau bestimmt wie sie sich fühlen und
darauf basierend Werbung auf sie zu
schneidet
einige der Übersetzungs-
möglicherweise sind die Auswirkungen auf
die Gesamtwirtschaft bereits zu spüren
im ersten Jahrzehnt dieses Jahrhunderts
wurde in den Vereinigten Staaten nicht
ein einziger Arbeitsplatz geschaffen
in den Vereinigten Staaten erleben wir
bereits einen sogenannten Aufschwung der
Arbeitslosigkeit
in der aktuellen Wirtschaftskrise sind
viele Arbeitnehmer von Entlassungen und
Kurzarbeit betroffen viele Unternehmen
nutzen die Technologie um die
Wiedereinstellung vieler Arbeitnehmer zu
vermeiden
dies ist ein ernstes Problem das ist zu
lösen gilt damit die Wirtschaft wieder
in Schwung kommt und die Menschen wieder
Arbeit finden
im Laufe der Geschichte hat Technologie
immer wieder zum Umdenken in Wirtschaft
und Gesellschaft geführt im späten 19
Jahrhundert waren 50% der us-arbeiter in
der Landwirtschaft beschäftigt im Jahr
2000 waren es weniger als 2%
. diese Arbeitnehmer fanden in anderen
sektorenarbeit aber Martin denkt dieses
Mal wird es anders kommen
die künstliche Intelligenz hat sich in
vielen Bereichen der Wirtschaft
ausgebreitet und das hat einige
Auswirkungen auf Arbeitnehmer es gibt
eine bestimmte Unsicherheit die mit der
Einführung neuer Technologien einhergeht
es gibt keine Sicherheit mehr auf die
Arbeitnehmer zurückgreifen können diese
Technologie ist überall zu finden daher
ist es wichtig dass die Arbeitnehmer
sich anpassen und sich auf die
Veränderungen in der Wirtschaft
einstellen um sich selbst und Ihre
Familie zu schützen
[Applaus]
was die neue Technologie so
allgegenwärtig macht ist die Entwicklung
einer neuen virtuellen Welt der Welt der
Big
dataine
ist im Wesentlichen die Sammlung und
Nutzung riesiger Datenmengen in großen
Unternehmen sammeln sie meist alle
möglichen Informationen über ihre Kunden
Ihre Geschäftsabläufe und die Prozesse
in der Industrie zum Beispiel über die
Bewegungsmuster ihrer Arbeiter in den
Fabriken
sind wertvolle Informationen und soll
intelligenten Algorithmen dazu dienen zu
lernen und herauszufinden wie Dinge
einfacher und besser gemacht werden
können und das ist etwas das meiner
Meinung nach in Zukunft zu großen
Problemen führen wird
die Gesamtmenge der weltweiten
Datenmenge wird inzwischen auf weit über
1.000 Milliarden Gigabyte geschätzt
es sind Big Data die den Fortschritt in
der Technologie vorantreiben zum
Beispiel die Fähigkeit der Maschinen zu
denken
man hört auf das Argument das Computer
nur das tun wozu sie programmiert wurden
aber das trifft auf heute natürlich
nicht mehr zu
maschinelles Lernen erlaubt es
intelligenten softwarealgorithmendaten
zu analysieren auf dieser Grundlage
können Sie dann Dinge erlernen neues
herausfinden und Vorhersagen treffen
es ist also nicht mehr länger der Mensch
der dem Computer sagt was er Schritt für
Schritt zu tun hat sondern der Computer
ist jetzt in der Lage es selbst
herauszufinden
in Zukunft wird jedes Gerät ja sogar
ganze Industrieanlagen miteinander
vernetzt sein und miteinander
kommunizieren
ich denke dass die künstliche
Intelligenz dies als eine Art Plattform
nutzen wird es wird sich ausweiten alles
wird intelligenter werden
beim letzten großen technologischen
Fortschritt ersetzten Roboter in
Fabriken und ein Fertigungsstraßen
Millionen von Arbeitern Martin glaubt
dass die neue Revolution auch die
Angestellten betreffen wird
sobald ein Computer lernt etwas zu tun
kann diese Information auf eine
beliebige Anzahl von Maschinen
übertragen werden man kann sich also
eine Mitarbeiter vorstellen der für eine
bestimmte Aufgabe ausgebildet wurde und
den man nun unendlich oft klonen kann so
ungefähr funktioniert künstliche
Intelligenz
maschinelles Lernen ist sehr gut
skalierbar wenn jemand sie täglich bei
ihren beruflichen Aufgaben begleitet
ihre Arbeitsabläufe studiert und zudem
Informationen aus ihren Handlungen
ziehen kann dann können Sie sicher sein
dass es irgendwann einen Algorithmus
geben wird der in der Lage ist ihren Job
zu machen und das trifft auf viele
Berufe zu
viele dieser Arbeitsplätze die verdrängt
werden könnten sind derzeit von gut
ausgebildeten hochbezahlten
Arbeitnehmern besetzt
man könnte sagen dass jeder der vor
einem Computer sitzt und eine Art von
routinemäßiger vorhersehbarer Arbeit
verrichtet zum Beispiel standardisierte
Berichte oder Analysen erstellt sehr
anfällig für KI ist besonders
interessant ist es im Bereich des
Journalismus hier gibt es bereits
Systeme die verschiedene Quellen im
Internet zu reißerischen Stories
zusammenfassen und diese überall
veröffentlichen
man kann sie nicht von einem manuell
geschriebenen Artikel unterscheiden in
Zukunft werden bestimmt 90% der
artikelmaschinell erstellt werden
die Zahl der wegfallenden Jobs hat das
Potenzial die wirtschaftslandschaft
grundlegend zu verändern
es gibt eine Reihe von Studien allen
voran die Universität
sie haben eine ganze Reihe von Ländern
untersucht mit dem Ergebnis das in den
nächsten 20 Jahren vielleicht 50% der
Arbeitsplätze automatisiert werden
könnten
de Zahl offensichtlich haben wir ein
massives soziales Problem die Regierung
wäre mit der Versorgung all dieser
Menschen wie kein Einkommen mehr haben
enorm überfordert ich glaube das ist so
eine massiven wirtschaftlichen Abschwung
kommen könnte weil die Verbraucher
wegfallen es gäbe keine Menschen mehr
die in der Lage wären die Produkte und
Dienstleistungen zu kaufen die von der
Wirtschaft produziert werden
eine Revolution von solchem Ausmaß würde
nicht nur unsere Wirtschaft verändern
nein sie hätte auch immense Auswirkungen
auf unsere Gesellschaft
[Musik]
das hätte einen massiven Anstieg der
Ungleichheit zur Folge wohlhabenden
Menschen die Zugang zu all dieser
Technologie haben werden außerordentlich
gut dastehen das könnte zu Unruhen
vielleicht sogar zu Aufständen oder
massiven verbrechenswellen in den
Vereinigten Staaten führen
während der Großen Depression hatten wir
eine Arbeitslosenquote von etwa
25%. damals gab es viele Menschen die
ernsthaft befürchteten dass dies zum
Zusammenbruch der Demokratie und des
Kapitalismus führen würde
diese Situation kommt im Ende der Welt
wie wir sie kennen sehr nah 11 Science
Fiction Albtraum wie aus dem Kino
es gibt einige sehr prominente visionäre
wie zum Beispiel Stephen Hawking oder
Elon Musk die echte Bedenken zum
Potenzial fortgeschrittener künstlicher
Intelligenz geäußert haben ihre Sorge
gilt eine super intelligenten Maschine
die wir vielleicht einmal bauen werden
stellen Sie sich eine Maschine vor die
100 oder 8000 mal intelligenter ist als
ein Mensch wie würde so ein System
handeln was ist wenn sie beschließt dass
wir nur eine Last sind und Sie uns
einfach loswerden möchte dies könnte
eine existenzielle Bedrohung darstellen
ich glaube das ist eine ernste Frage und
nichts über das man lachen und es
einfach abtun sollte
es gibt hier keine Grenzen es gibt
keinen Punkt an dem man sagen kann das
war's weiter kommen wir nicht über
diesen Punkt kommen Maschinen nicht
hinaus
wir erreichen nun eine Ära in der die
Dinge anders funktionieren werden und
darauf müssen wir uns einstellen
das Gesundheitswesen ist
schon eingestellt hat
Forscher hoffen dass Mensch und Maschine
gemeinsam das Wohl aller erhöhen können
[Musik]
die vierte industrielle Revolution das
Zeitalter der künstlichen Intelligenz
ist angebrochen Computer bewältigen
komplexe Aufgaben was einst als
alleinige Aufgabe den Menschen galt
Wirtschafts-
generell werden Roboter in der einen
oder anderen Form immer wichtiger das
ist gut denn sie werden viele stupide
Tätigkeiten ersetzen die derzeit noch
von Menschen erledigt werden müssen
Roboter werden einen dramatischen
Einfluss auf den Arbeitsmarkt haben sie
senken die Produktionskosten und können
so gut wie jede manuelle Aufgabe
erledigen
ford hat in seinen Büchern auf die
Bedrohung des Arbeitsmarktes hingewiesen
aber auch er sieht Bereiche in denen
künstliche Intelligenz von Vorteil sein
könnte ich glaube dass das
Gesundheitswesen tatsächlich eine der
Bereiche ist in dem sich künstliche
Intelligenz und Robotik in Zukunft
außerordentlich positiv auswirken
könnten die Belastung für unsere
Wirtschaft wächst insbesondere in den
Vereinigten Staaten künstliche
Intelligenz und Robotik könnten uns
dabei helfen effizienter zu sein
analysten gehen davon aus dass der
ki-markt im Gesundheitswesen bis zum
Jahr 2021 einen Umsatz von über 6
Milliarden Dollar erzielen wird fast dem
zehnfachen der derzeitigen Gesamtsumme
entspricht junge Unternehmen wie
heinzelt
in Kalifornien werden die Daten von
Patienten aus um die Behandlung von
Krankheiten zu verbessern
ein von IBM Forschern entwickeltes
intelligente Softwaresystem ist ein
revolutionärer Vorreiter
es kann den Persönlichkeitstyp einer
Person erkennen es kann sich zum
Beispiel E-Mails ansehen und ihnen sagen
in welchem Ton sie geschrieben sind
unabhängig davon ob es beabsichtigt war
oder nicht es kann eine großen wissens-
Watson arbeitet im Bereich der Big Data
und bezieht sein Wissen aus Milliarden
von Fakten und Zahlen die im Cyberspace
kursieren ein look at the world ich
betrachte die Welt aus dem Blickwinkel
der Datenmenge also der Menge an Wissen
oder Erkenntnissen die in den Daten
enthalten sind die wir aber nicht
extrahieren können weil wir dazu nicht
in der Lage sind und daraus vielleicht
die falschen Schlüsse ziehen
die vierte industrielle Revolution
besteht für mich also darin dass wir die
Welt anhand dieser bisher versteckten
Daten viel besser verstehen können
IBM für derzeit ein Forschungsprojekt
durch bei dem Watson medizinische
Fachkräfte unterstützt und Ärzten bei
der Behandlung gefährlicher Krankheiten
einschließlich Hautkrebs hilft
das Melanom ist eine der tödlichsten
Formen des Hautkrebses bei der die
Früherkennung und das Eingreifen
entscheidend sind
die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines Melanoms
bei Patienten mit Leberflecken selbst
einschätzen
[Musik]
leider sind Fehler hier manchmal
unausweichlich
einige Melanome werden übersehen und
einige Hautflecken die vollkommen
gutartig sind werden unnötigerweise
entfernt
hier kann uns eine KI also helfen der
Computer kann anhand eines Fotos eine
Tiefenanalyse vornehmen und es so
automatisch analysieren
er sagt uns dann dass es sich bei diesem
Bild mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit um ein
Melanom handelt
unsere eigene interne Retrospektive
Forschung hat ergeben dass der Computer
eine Genauigkeit von 95% erreicht
führende klinische Experten haben eine
Quote bis zu 84% ein Melanom zu erkennen
wir wollen also nicht den klinischen
Experten ersetzen viel mehr bietet es
ihm eine zusätzliche Analyse der Bilder
von Hautläsionen durch den Abgleich mit
Datenbank
in dieser Vision sollen in Zukunft
Mensch und Maschine Hand in Hand
arbeiten und ihre Fähigkeiten
gegenseitig ergänzen
ich freue mich auf eine Zeit in der
jeder Berufstätige also zwei oder drei
Milliarden Berufstätige auf der ganzen
Welt einen eigenen persönlichen
kognitiven Assistenten haben werden der
ihnen bei ihrer täglichen Arbeit hilft
und das wird die Art des Fachwissens
verändern die Menschheit wird sich in
Bezug auf das Fachwissen und die Art und
Weise wie wir unser Wissen und unsere
Erfahrung auf reale Probleme anwenden
und damit die Welt verbessern in eine
völlig andere Richtung bewegen
genau wie in den vorangegangenen
industriellen Revolutionen als Maschinen
die Arbeit der Menschen erleichterte und
ihnen half riesige Informationsmengen zu
verarbeiten die nächste Revolution wird
die kognitiven Fähigkeiten des Menschen
durch Maschinen erweitern so stelle ich
mir das vor
Martin Ford bleibt skeptisch und glaubt
dass künstliche Intelligenz für uns eine
große Herausforderung darstellt und
unsere Art zu leben und arbeiten
grundlegend verändern wird
wir sind auf diese kommenden
Veränderungen nicht vorbereitet die
Dinge werden sich deutlich
verschlechtern bevor die positiven
Effekte einsetzen das gilt insbesondere
für die Auswirkungen auf Arbeitsmarkt
und Lebensunterhalt für Verbraucher und
VerbraucherInnen die kurzfristigen
Effekte werden also eine
Verschlechterung der Lage herbeiführen
langfristig sieht es eher optimistisch
aus
man kann sich in etwa eine Zukunft
vorstellen in der niemand mehr einen
gefährlichen Job machen muss oder eine
Arbeit nachgehen muss die er hasst oder
eine nicht ausfüllt diese Jobs werden in
der Zukunft immer mehr durch die
Technologie übernommen wenn wir erst
diesen Punkt erreicht haben dann ist das
natürlich ein ungemein positives
Ergebnis ich glaube also durchaus an
diese positiven Effekte und das ist
eines der besten Dinge ist die der
Menschheit je widerfahren wird aber wir
brauchen Zeit um uns darauf einzustellen
und das ist die wahre Herausforderung
zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte leben
mehr Menschen in der Stadt als auf dem
Land
[Musik]
die Stadtbevölkerung der Welt wächst
jedes Jahr um 70 Millionen Menschen ca
300 Städte erwirtschaften 50% des
globalen bruttoinlandsprodukte ist bis
2025 wird dieser Anteil sogar auf 66%
steigen
wenn es also unseren Städten schlecht
geht hat das weitreichende Folgen für
die Menschheit
Städte sind sowohl für unsere eigene
Wirtschaft als auch für den Fortschritt
der Weltwirtschaft von entscheidender
Bedeutung
sie können chaotisch aber auch treibende
Kraft unserer Entwicklung sein
Städte können Wohlstand bringen aber
auch gefährliche Orte sein Denken
und lebendig
einer der wichtigsten Faktoren für die
Organisierung sind die vielen
Möglichkeiten die eine Stadt bietet
nehmen wir an Sie sind Pharma und Leben
auf dem Land dort haben sie wenig
Möglichkeiten mal etwas anderes zu
erleben ihre Freunde ziehen alle in die
Stadt und bekommen Bürojobs oder einen
gut bezahlten Job an einem wichtigen
Produktionsstandort es gibt Restaurants
es gibt Kultur das Leben pulsiert das
ist natürlich attraktiv und sieht
Menschen an die daran teilhaben wollen
alles ist relativ sie werden einen
besseren Zugang zu Schulen haben einen
besseren Zugang zu medizinischer
Versorgung einen besseren Zugang zu
Arbeitsplätzen sie leben einfach
wirtschaftlich sicherer
[Musik]
um 1912 befanden sich die größten Städte
der Welt in Nordamerika oder Europa
hundert Jahre später sind es nur noch
zwei die großen Städte der Zukunft
werden in denen sich schnell
entwickelnden Volkswirtschaften Asiens
und Afrikas leben
der größte Teil des Städte Wachstums
wird in China Indien und Nigeria
stattfinden allein auf diese drei Länder
werden 37% der weltweiten
Stadtbevölkerung entfallen
schwindelerregende zahlen
Lagos zum Beispiel die größte Stadt
Nigerias hat ein Bevölkerungswachstum
pro Jahr die der Größe von Boston
gleicht
die Organisierung in den USA und Japan
liegt bei über 70 Prozent in China liegt
sie immer noch bei ca 50 China wird also
irgendwann eine Menge riesiger mega
Städte haben die viel größer sind als
wir sie uns heute vorstellen können und
nicht nur in China sondern insbesondere
in vielen Schwellenländern überall dort
wo es große Bevölkerungszahlen gibt
diesen Trend werden wir die nächsten 50
Jahre erleben
die unglaubliche Wachstumsrate macht die
Verwaltung einer Großstadt noch
schwieriger
die größten Risiken mit denen die uns in
unseren Städten konfrontiert sehen sind
dieselben Risiken die uns alle betreffen
Politik Klimawandel wirtschaftliche
Ungleichheit Produktivität
Wirtschaftswachstum Beschäftigung
Bildung Verkehr
es sind die gleichen Probleme die wir
überall sehen nur eben in einer sehr
stark konzentrierten Form
Rio de Janeiro in Brasilien ist eine
Stadt die mit vielen dieser Probleme
kämpft
Alessandra Orofino versucht diese
Probleme zu lösen sie ist der Meinung
dass die größten Städte der Welt Gefahr
laufen in einer Flut von Armut
verfallener Infrastruktur und
Gleichgültigkeit zu versenken wenn
nichts dagegen unternommen wird werden
Milliarden von Menschen unter den Folgen
leiden
Art der Urbanisierung beibehalten werden
wir schnell an unsere Grenzen stoßen
wenn wir nicht anfangen unsere
städtekonzepte zu überdenken wird es für
uns unmöglich werden Städte zu verwalten
und in ihnen zu leben es werden keine
fröhlichen Orte sein ich denke wenn wir
den Wachstumsprozess ändern könnten sich
diese Grenzen verlagern und
möglicherweise gar verschwenden das ist
aber voraus dass wir gründlich über das
Umfeld in dem wir leben wollen
nachdenken und auch wie wir es gemeinsam
besser gestalten können
die Verwaltung von Mega Städten ist eine
der großen Herausforderungen unserer
Zeit in Rio de Janeiro drängen sich ca
12 Millionen Menschen in den
Ballungsräumen die Stadt ist schön und
lebendig hat aber auch mit Kriminalität
Ungleichheit und Armut zu kämpfen
Alessandra ist eine urbaner Aktivistin
die in Megastädten auf drei
verschiedenen Kontinenten gelebt und
gearbeitet hat sie hat zusammen mit den
Vereinten Nationen an den Zielen für
nachhaltige Entwicklung gearbeitet und
eine NGO namens
diese nutzt von den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern gesammelte Daten um
kampagnengelder zu beschaffen und so
Probleme zu lösen die durch das schnelle
Wachstum der Stadt entstehen mehr yoriot
hat 170.000 Aktivisten Alessandra hofft
dass es ein Modell für andere schnell
wachsende Städte werden kann
wir setzen hier sehr stark auf die
Tradition der nachbarschaftsgemeinschaft
nicht nur in Brasilien sondern überall
auf der Welt wir versuchen diese
Tradition uns 21 Jahrhundert zu
transportieren ich wuchs in Rio de
Janeiro auf mein Vater stammt aus einem
Viertel in Rio das in den 90er Jahren
ziemlich gefährlich ziemlich arm war
also aus der unteren Mittelschicht
meine Mutter kommt aus sehr wohlhabenden
Verhältnissen aus einer der reichsten
gegen den Rios das hat mir gezeigt dass
diese Stadt sehr vielfältig aber auch
sehr rau und ungleich sein kann und das
ist nicht nur in Rio so sondern das
beobachtet man in Städten auf der ganzen
Welt
[Musik]
Rio de Janeiro hat wie viele andere
Städte auch sehr wohlhabende Stadtteile
andere dagegen bleiben verarmt und sind
abgeschnitten
Alessandra ist überzeugt dass die
Überwindung dieser Kluft für alle von
großem Nutzen sein wird
in den Städten sind die Menschen sich
näher es gibt diese Intensität diese
dichte es sind Orte an denen
Innovationen auf natürliche Weise
entstehen
denn es ist schwierig neue Ideen zu
entwickeln wenn man immer mit denselben
Leuten spricht und die selben Themen hat
Städte sind natürliche Zentren für
Innovation und in den meisten Ländern
die Motoren für wirtschaftliches
Wachstum
[Musik]
wenn dieses Wachstum jedoch schnell und
ungeplant erfolgt führt dies zu
verstopften Straßen vergifteter Luft und
einer unzureichenden Infrastruktur
ich komme aus einer Stadt die sehr
schnell gewachsen ist
wie kann man Gehwege ab was das Systeme
Schulen und Mobilitätssysteme für eine
schnell wachsende Bevölkerung schaffen
und wenn große Ungleichheit mit ins
Spiel kommen ist die Herausforderung des
rasanten Wachstums in diesem Umfeld noch
größer
in einer mega Stadt kann die größte
Herausforderung sein von A nach B zu
kommen
unsere Mobilitätssysteme sind im
Allgemeinen in einem schlechten Zustand
mit wenigen Ausnahmen unser System
schließt ganze Bevölkerungsgruppen aus
alle Möglichkeiten einer Stadt täglich
nutzen zu können
es ist für sie sehr schwer sich
vorzubewegen
damit werden aber auch die besser
gestellten daran gehindert andere Orte
der Stadt kennenzulernen
man schafft also eine Stadt in der jeder
in seinem eigenen Territorium lebt das
ist schlimm
an erster Stelle dieser
Infrastrukturprobleme stehen die armen
sie können von den wirtschaftlichen
Möglichkeiten die das Leben in einer
Stadt bietet physisch abgeschnitten
werden die armen sind natürlich die
hauptleitragenden niemand von uns sollte
einfach so akzeptieren dass in den
Entwicklungsländern ein Drittel der
Bevölkerung ins Lamms lebt wir werden
immer mehr und müssen uns damit
auseinandersetzen wie wir in Zukunft
leben wollen
das Ergebnis einer schnellen ungeplanten
Expansion sind Slums heute leben
schätzungsweise 863 Millionen Menschen
ins Lamms während die 104 Millionen
slambewohner in Indien eine eigene
Nation während sie das 13
bevölkerungsreichste Land der Welt aber
Slums sind nicht immer hoffnungslose
Orte
die armen warten nicht darauf dass ihre
Regierung endlich etwas tut sie schaffen
ihr eigenes städtisches Umfeld wenn sie
sich die Slums in Rio anschauen sehen
sie dass der größte Teil der
Infrastruktur im Laufe der Jahre von der
Gemeinschaft selbst gebaut wurde
es gibt also ein gewisses Maß an
Eigeninitiative dass man in armen aber
auch in reichenvierteln häufiger
antrifft weil die Regierung nichts tut
das bedeutet dass Stadtplaner mit Slams
behutsam umgehen müssen
was machen wir also mit Gebieten die von
Gemeinden erschlossen wurden denen es
aber an Infrastruktur mangelt selbst mit
etwas gutem Willen um diese Gebiete mit
qualitativ hochwertigen öffentlichen
Dienstleistungen zu versorgen müssen wir
entscheiden welche Teile dieser
Infrastruktur wir belassen wenn wir
etwas verändern müssen wir dabei
bedenken dass es von der Community
selbst gebaut wurde dieser Prozess muss
klug und mit Empathie angegangen werden
es müssen die Interessen dieser
Gemeinschaften geschützt werden sonst
kann es zu massiven Verwerfungen und
Zerstörungen im sozialen Gefüge kommen
das ist lebenswichtig
hier in Rio gibt es ein Viertel namens
Santa Teresa in dieser Nachbarschaft
haben wir eine schöne historische
Straßenbahn die meisten Bahnen in Rio
wurden im frühen 20 Jahrhundert zerstört
in Santa Teresa schlossen sich Nachbarn
zusammen und kämpften dafür ihre
Straßenbahn zu behalten sie sehr stolz
darauf im Laufe der Zeit Gerät Santa
Teresa etwas in Vergessenheit und die
Armut wuchs aber in den letzten fünf bis
sechs Jahren hat sich das Viertel sehr
schnell erholt und die Regierung
beschloss diese historische Straßenbahn
die eine der letzten der Stadt ist in
eine Touristenattraktion zu verwandeln
aber es waren die Nachbarn die damals
für diese Straßenbahn kämpften weshalb
sie heute noch existiert das liegt daran
dass sie sich gemeinschaftlich
organisierten sie haben diesen Wert
erhalten und somit den Reichtum ihrer
Gemeinschaft geschaffen sowas sehen wir
auf der ganzen Welt
Alessandra glaubt das Städte diese
Kreativität oft ignorieren das Ergebnis
ist ein Demokratie definiert dass das
Vertrauen in die Stadtverwaltung
untergräbt und bereits gefährdete
Gemeinschaften entfremdet sie glaubt
auch das Städte ihre Bürger involvieren
müssen wenn sie erfolgreich expandieren
wollen
ich denke was definitiv falsch läuft ist
dass wir die Bürger nicht in den Prozess
der Planung mit einbeziehen ich habe
noch keine Stadt gesehen die das
kollektive Wissen ihrer Gemeinschaft
nutzt so dass diese tatsächlich Einfluss
auf die Entwicklung der Stadt nehmen
könnte wenn wir das ändern werden wir
auch alle anderen Probleme lösen
aber damit wir das Potenzial unserer
Städte vollständig nutzen können müssen
wir zuerst die Spaltung innerhalb der
Städte überwinden
wenn wir weiterhin ausgegrenzte
communities in Städten schaffen in denen
der Großteil der Bevölkerung in Armut
lebt glaube ich nicht dass wir
glückliche urbane Räume haben können
Städte die keine Seele haben und daher
auch immer unattraktiver für Unternehmen
und für Menschen werden die dort leben
wollen um neue wirtschaftliche
Strukturen zu schaffen letztendlich wird
die Armut steigen
jenseits des Ozeans wächst eine weitere
riesige Stadt lagos ist heute die
wirtschaftlich wichtigste Stadt Afrikas
aber sie wächst gnadenlos und bedroht so
die Zukunft von 21 Millionen Menschen
[Musik]
als je zuvor leben entstehten
aber viele der größten Städte haben zu
kämpfen
Lagos an der nigerianischen
Atlantikküste ist die größte Stadt der
Welt ohne ein flächendeckendes
Schienennetz so dass jeder auf die
Straße angewiesen ist
für Arbeiter wie Abraham Cole bedeutet
dies tägliches Pendeln wann sind sie
heute aufgestanden
heute bin ich so gegen 3 Uhr
aufgestanden gegen 3:30 Uhr
normalerweise frühstücke ich nicht das
kostet zu viel Zeit
innerhalb von drei Jahren hat sich die
Bevölkerung von Lagos von 11 Millionen
auf 21 Millionen fast verdoppelt doch
diese enorme Expansion hat die verarmte
Infrastruktur der Stadt überfordert wie
lange dauert die Fahrt ins Büro ich
fahre ungefähr 45 Minuten ins Büro und
im Berufsverkehr wie lange brauchen sie
da
gewöhnlich stehe ich sechs bis sieben
Stunden am Tag im Stau
meistens benötige ich drei Stunden für
den Hinweg und drei bis vier Stunden
zurück der Rückweg dauert meist länger
die Rückfahrt ist echt das schlimmste
und ganz bestimmt will ich nicht für den
Rest meines Lebens sieben Stunden meiner
täglichen Zeit vergeuden every day time
[Musik]
Lagos gehört zu den fünf am wenigsten
lebenswerten Städten der Welt doch
obwohl die Wirtschaft dort größer ist
als die Kenias ist es für die Millionen
von Arbeitnehmern eine tägliche Tortur
an ihren Arbeitsplatz zu kommen
und wann sehen sie ihre Kinder
am Wochenende eigentlich nur an den
Wochenende
manchmal sehe ich sie auch unter der
Woche wenn sie mich sehen wollen oder
ist wichtig ist sie zu sehen manchmal
vermissen sie mich schon sehr das muss
ziemlich schwierig sein
ja es ist schwer aber im Moment müssen
wir das so machen
[Musik]
die Millionen von Arbeitnehmern in Lagos
macht auch Abraham wenn er zur Arbeit
kommt erst einmal ein Nickerchen
da sind wir
willkommen in meinem Büro was machen sie
jetzt als erstes ich denke ich jetzt
haben wir es zehn nach sieben
ich werde mich kurz für 10 Minuten noch
mal hinlegen und dann bin ich bereit zu
arbeiten
jeden Tag wandern ca 2000 Menschen
dauerhaft nach Lagos ein was die
Infrastruktur der Stadt sehr belastet
und somit vom Land zu Meer hinausdehnt
das Ergebnis in Slums wie Marco eine
schwimmende Siedlung in der Lagune der
Stadt
[Musik]
die Infrastruktur hat mit dem
Bevölkerungswachstum nicht Schritt
gehalten
grundlegende Aspekte der Lebensqualität
wie der Zugang zu sauberem Wasser oder
zu Elektrizität sind daher begrenzt
bevor man also überhaupt zu Fragen des
Wachstums und der Entwicklung kommt
müssen Lagos bzw Nigeria noch viel
grundlegende Fragen der Infrastruktur
klären
ist der älteste Slum in Lagos 80.000
Menschen leben hier in Stelzen Gebäuden
die durch ein komplexes Kanalsystem
miteinander verbunden sind
erfolgreiche stadtkonzepte finden Wege
um selbst den Ärmsten der Armen
Dienstleistungen zukommen zu lassen und
genau darin liegt die Herausforderung
insbesondere in den Entwicklungsländern
wo die Ressourcen knapp sind
in Marokko haben die Bewohner ihre
eigene Infrastruktur entwickelt
einschließlich Frischwasser und Strom
diese dreistöckige schwimmende Schule
die auch als Gemeindezentrum dient ist
das jüngste Projekt dieser einzigartigen
Community die Schule wurde im Jahr 2013
fertiggestellt sie ist billig und
einfach zu bauen ihre Konstrukteure
hoffen dass sie als Vorbild für künftige
Gebäude in Marokko dienen wird
zum Beispiel interessante Fragen zur
Verwaltung und Kontrolle auf das Gebiet
wurde lange Zeit vernachlässigt so dass
die Anwohner aus eigenem Antrieb heraus
selbst eine Schule und ein Lokal
errichtet haben sie führen ihre eigenen
Entwicklungsprojekte um die
Lebensverhältnisse zu verbessern
die zentrale Regierung möchte jedoch
dieses Gebiet für ihre eigenen Zwecke
verwenden
[Musik]
nur wenige Kilometer entfernt entsteht
eine andere Vision wie Lagos ich hätte
entwickeln können keine
gemeinschaftliche Vision sondern ein
Großprojekt von unglaublichem Ausmaß Eco
Atlantic
wo wir jetzt gerade stehen befinden wir
uns in der Ausrichtung des
finanzdistrikts den wir ecob Boulevard
oder manche auch unsere eigene Fifth
Avenue nennen
hier werden alle großen Finanzinstitute
ihre Hauptzentrale bzw Büros einrichten
Atlantik ist ein milliardenschweres
Wohn- und Geschäftsviertel das auf zehn
Quadratkilometern neu gewonnen im Land
errichtet wurde und eine eigene neue
Stadt darstellt die Befürworter hoffen
dass eines Tages eine viertel Millionen
Menschen hier leben werden während
150.000 Arbeiter täglich aus der alten
Stadt übers Wasser pendeln
[Musik]
als wir anfingen Atlantic zu konzipieren
haben wir natürlich geschaut was
passiert gerade in Dubai oder in Canary
warf in London
wenn man sich heute die Innenstädte von
London Paris oder New York anschaut
Leben dort natürlich meist eher
wohlhabende Menschen ich selbst könnte
mir keine Wohnung in Londons Innenstadt
leisten Gott
aber ermöglicht man es solchen Leuten
dort zu wohnen schafft man gleichzeitig
auch Arbeitsplätze
darum ist es in Nigeria üblich dass bei
der Errichtung einer Wohnung auch gleich
Unterkünfte für das Hauspersonal der
Familie geschaffen werden
man muss sich immer klar vor Augen
führen dass es sich hier um eine
Stadtentwicklung und nicht um eine
Siedlung für Geringverdiener handelt es
ist ein Geschäftszentrum das in erster
Linie die Zukunft für die kommerzielle
Entwicklung von Lagos darstellt daran
besteht kein Zweifel
David hofft dass die ersten
Wohneinheiten bis Ende 2016 fertig
werden und die gesamte Infrastruktur bis
2022 fertiggestellt ist projects
Projekte wie Eco Atlantik werfen ebenso
viele Fragen auf wie sie Antworten geben
vor allem dann wenn Anwohnern klar
bewusst ist dass sie möglicherweise den
Kürzeren ziehen werden
andererseits bieten sie die Möglichkeit
neu anzufangen und Strukturen wie
Schulen Krankenhäuser Büros und
Verkehrseinrichtungen von Anfang an zu
schaffen
sie geben ebenso riesigen Städten wie
Lagos die Möglichkeit ein Modell zu
schaffen in den Planung und Ausführung
stattfindet und Konzepte erarbeitet
werden
[Musik]
die Zukunft von Megastädten wie Lagos
bleibt ungewiss ob organisches von den
Bürgern getragenes Wachstum wie in
makoko oder groß angelegte geplante
Entwicklung wie Eco Atlantik klar ist
das unkontrollierte Wachstum das immense
Potenzial der Städte zerstören könnte
ich schaue optimistisch auf die Zukunft
unserer Städte ich wuchs in New York in
den 70er Jahren auf als die Stadt am
Rande des bankrots stand jetzt im 21
Jahrhundert wohnt New York es ist ein
großartiger Ort man kann sehen was mit
der richtigen Planung und einer
vielfältigen und lebendigen Bevölkerung
alles möglich ist
ich hoffe dass diese globalen Städte
extrem vernetzt sein werden dass die
über solidaritätsnetzwerke und
resilienz-netzwerke verfügen so dass man
das Gefühl hat in einer schönen fairen
Stadt zu leben wo man sich entfalten
kann das ist die Art von Projekt die wir
anstreben sie können sich gegenseitig
besuchen sie können auf der globalen
Bühne voneinander lernen
[Musik]
die Arbeitswelt wird immer noch von
Männern dominiert im Nahen Osten und in
Nordafrika sind nur 25% der Frauen
erwerbstätig weltweit wird drei Viertel
der unbezahlten Arbeit von Frauen
geleistet und selbst in US-Unternehmen
haben 25 Prozent der weiblichen
Beschäftigten das Gefühl dass ihr
Geschlecht sie benachteiligt
wenn Frauen die Hälfte des Volkes
ausmachen sollten Sie auch eine faire
Chance auf dem Arbeitsmarkt bekommen sie
sollten fairerweise den gleichen Beitrag
zur Wirtschaft leisten wie Männer also
einen weitaus größeren Anteil wie in der
Vergangenheit nur etwa 5% der
unternehmensvorstände werden von Frauen
geleitet weniger als 20% der
Entscheidungsträger in den
unternehmensvorständen sind Frauen
derzeit sind im US-Kongress nur etwa 20%
der gewählten Vertreter sowohl im Senat
als auch im Repräsentanten Hausfrauen
frauen verdienen etwa 79 Cent eines
männlichen dauers sie werden auch viele
Arten benachteiligt
wisst der sogenannte gender-gap er
existiert seit lange
die Organisation alle mächtigen
Organisationen unserer Zeit die
Regierung große Unternehmen die
Bildungsstruktur unser Gesundheitssystem
werden an der Spitze von Männern
dominiert das ist historisch gewachsen
und geht bis weit ins 20 Jahrhundert und
davor zurück
es dauerte eine Weile bis Frauen die
sogenannte gläserne Decke durchbrechen
konnten aber gleichzeitig braucht es
auch Zeit bis sich die Gesellschaft
darauf eingestellt hat dass Männer und
Frauen an der Spitze einer dieser
Institutionen gleichberechtigt sind
fast 100 Jahre nach dem Frauen in den
Vereinigten Staaten das Wahlrecht
zugesprochen wurde ist die Kluft
zwischen den Geschlechtern nach wie vor
auf der ganzen Welt präsent die
Überwindung ist mehr als nur eine Frage
der fernes es ist zu einem
wirtschaftlichen Gebot geworden das
nicht nur in Davos sondern auf der
ganzen Welt diskutiert wird
die Kluft zwischen den Geschlechtern hat
durchaus Auswirkungen auf unsere
Wirtschaft es kann die Chancen am Markt
beeinträchtigen oder den potenziellen
Verlust im Ergebnis verringern wenn die
Belegschaft Ihres Unternehmens auch den
Markt repräsentiert werden sie eher
erfolgreich sein bei having ain more
diverse workforce Unternehmen mit einer
vielfältigeren Belegschaft sind in der
Regel erfolgreicher weil sie in der Lage
sind Herausforderungen Probleme und
Innovationen kreativer anzugehen wenn
Sie also einen Vorstand oder einen
Ausschuss haben der ausschließlich aus
Personen besteht die alle ähnliche
Schulen besucht haben den gleichen
background besitzen und ähnlich denken
werden sie weniger erfolgreich sein als
ein viel diverser Vorstand
aus einer Studie die im letzten Herbst
von mckinse veröffentlicht wurde geht
hervor dass eine Angleichung des
wirtschaftlichen Beitrags der Frauen in
großen Unternehmen bzw in
Volkswirtschaften die Weltwirtschaft bis
2025 um 26 Millionen Dollar anheben
würde
also wirklich große zahlen wenn es darum
geht Frauen den gleichen
wirtschaftlichen Beitrag zuzusprechen
es zeigen sich immer mehr positive
Effekte durch Frauen an der Spitze von
Unternehmen
wenn man sich Unternehmen ansieht in
denen es weibliche CEOs oder Vorsitzende
gibt dann sind das meist Unternehmen mit
guter Corporate Governance
es gibt weniger Ungerechtigkeit sie
haben meist auch keine ungleichen
Stimmrechte dadurch behält das Innere
Management die Kontrolle und sie haben
keine getrennten Vorstandswahlen
Unternehmen mit guter
Unternehmensführung haben eher weibliche
cIOS
es stellt sich also die Frage was hält
Frauen davon ab ganz oben auf der
wirtschaftlichen und politischen Ebene
zu stehen liegt es an mangelndem Ehrgeiz
oder ist es wie so oft Sexismus
betrachtet man also die berufstätigen
Frauen so geben etwa 43% von ihnen
irgendwann ihren Beruf auf um sich um
ein Kind aber auch um ältere Angehörige
zu kümmern es ist sehr schwierig wieder
in den Beruf einzusteigen und zwar auf
dem gleichen Niveau wie die männlichen
Kollegen die in den letzten 10 Jahren
dort tätig waren
die ehemalige Beamtin des
Außenministeriums an Mary slaughter hält
diese Erklärung für schlüssig sie ist
der Meinung dass die Struktur unserer
Arbeitsplätze und Gesellschaft und
Frauen benachteiligt wenn wir daran
nichts ändern werden Unternehmen und
Regierungen weiterhin schlecht performen
es gibt kein globales Problem das nicht
durch die Förderung von Frauen oder die
Verwirklichung von Gleichberechtigung
gelöst werden könnte wir wollen eine
Welt in der jeder Mensch ob Junge oder
Mädchen das Recht und die Fähigkeit hat
sein gottgegebenes Potenzial
auszuschöpfen momentan leben wir in
einer Welt wo Männer viel mehr
Möglichkeiten besitzen als Frauen
[Musik]
einst wurde den Frauen versprochen sie
könnten alles haben doch irgendetwas
hält sie davon ab die höchsten
Positionen in Wirtschaft und Regierung
zu erreichen
Emery slaughter hat in ihrer Karriere
vieles erreicht zwei Jahre lang
arbeitete sie für Außenministerin
Hillary Clinton und half dabei die
langfristigen Ziele der US-Außenpolitik
zu gestalten heute leitet sie den Think
Tank new America in Washington DC doch
erst ein Artikel in die Atlantik aus dem
Jahr 2012 der später auch in ihrem Buch
erschien festigte ihren Ruf als eine der
verfächterinnen zum Thema Frauen an der
Macht ohne question
in der feministischen Bewegung geht es
um Gleichberechtigung es geht darum dass
Frauen das haben können was Männer schon
immer hatten nämlich eine erfüllende
Tätigkeit oder eine Machtposition soweit
man so etwas möchte einer wichtigen
verantwortungsvollen Arbeit die einem
etwas bedeutet nachzugehen und eine
eigene Familie zu haben ist etwas was
Männer und Frauen gemeinsam schaffen
können prinzipiell denke ich gibt es
nichts was uns daran hindern könnte wie
es zu erreichen aber das heißt auch dass
wir jetzt anfangen und große
Veränderungen vornehmen müssen wenn wir
dieses Ziel erreichen wollen denn so wie
unsere Arbeitswelt derzeit strukturiert
ist so wie wir über Karrieren denken
müssen viel zu viele Menschen eine
weiter treffen und viel zu viele dieser
Menschen sind Frauen
diese Entscheidung musste Emmerich
slaughter ganz allein treffen
die Arbeit im Außenministerium auf hohe
Ebene ist eine die vom Zustand der Welt
abhängt die Welt ist per Definition
unberechenbar und das bedeutet eine
Menge Arbeit wenn in Ägypten eine
Revolution ausbricht kann man nicht
sagen okay ich bin dann am Montag wieder
da man muss präsent sein wenn etwas
passiert man kann also sagen ich habe
zwei Jahre lang sehr sehr lange
gearbeitet als ich zum Außenministerium
ging verstand meine Familie dass sie
Opfer bringen müsse damit ich meiner
Karriere nachgehen kann sie blieben in
prinstern ich arbeitete in Washington
ich bin montags um 5 Uhr morgens von zu
Hause losgefahren und kam freitags erst
spät zurück das war für alle schwierig
aber ich verstand dass das nötig war um
diesen Job zu machen als ich nach
Washington ging kam mein ältester Sohn
gerade in die Pubertät
er hatte eine sehr schwierige Phase er
fing an wirklich schlechter
Entscheidungen zu treffen so dass sich
einige Male mitten am Tag in den Zug
springen und nach Hause fahren musste
Ministerin Quinton war unglaublich
verständnisvoll
nach zwei Jahren aber wurde uns klar
dass wir uns entscheiden mussten wollen
wir uns ganz auf meine Karriere
konzentrieren oder wollen wir unseren
Kindern dabei helfen den richtigen Weg
einzuschlagen
die Entscheidung Ihren Traumjob
aufzugeben und Washington zu verlassen
hatte nicht nur Auswirkungen auf ihre
Karriere es stellte das feministische
Credo in Frage nachdem sie ihr Leben
lang gestrickt hatte
[Musik]
ich sah die Welt mit anderen Augen mir
wurde klar dass ich den Frauen den
jungen Studentinnen seit Jahrzehnten
gesagt hatte wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
alles schaffen ihr müsst hart dafür
arbeiten aber ihr könnt es schaffen doch
nun seien Sie dass sich aufgab jemand
wie ich jemand der alle Privilegien
genießt Geld einen Ehemann der sich
hauptsächlich um die Kinder kümmert wenn
selbst ich das mit all meinen
Möglichkeiten nicht schaffe das war eine
Offenbarung und hat mir die Augen
geöffnet und mir gezeigt dass man sich
entscheiden muss
Entscheidung die Familie ihrer Karriere
vorzuziehen brachte ihr den Vorwurf des
Verrats am Feminismus
eins mein Artikel im Atlantic erschien
erntete ich viel Kritik
Frauen meiner Generation oder älter
Feministinnen Frauen die ich bewunderte
waren besorgt dass der Artikel die
Bewegung bei zurückwerfen würde
für meine Familie da zu sein reagierten
viele Leute verständnislos und
enttäuscht
viele Frauen sahen mich nun mit anderen
Augen waren enttäuscht und warfen mir
vor nicht genug motiviert oder ehrgeizig
zu sein das war ziemlich frustrierend
[Musik]
lösten eine Debatte darüber aus ob
Frauen wirklich alles haben können
Facebook CEO Sandburg meint dass Frauen
angesichts der männlichen macht am
Arbeitsplatz selbstbewusster auftreten
und sich mehr einbringen müssten um
weiter voranzukommen
ich bewundere shall Sandberg und ich
bewundere was sie mit lean in bewirkt
hat ich habe das ganze als
Führungspersönlichkeit einer
Organisation erlebt junge Frauen kamen
zu mir und warten mich um eine
Gehaltserhöhung und ich wusste genau sie
halten vorher ihn gelesen sie taten
genau das was Shell Sandburg ihnen im
Fall und wofür viele Frauen eintreten
sollten
und das ist der richtige Weg ich denke
es sollte darum gehen wo unsere
Prioritäten liegen
dass das Problem komplexer ist und nicht
im Verhalten der Frauen zu suchen ist
unsere ganze Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft
ist einseitig strukturiert für Frauen
ist es fast unmöglich Karriere zu machen
und sich gleichzeitig um eine Familie zu
kümmern
[Musik]
diesen Vollzeitjob muss jemand machen
traditionell haben das die Frauen
erledigt also wird von den Frauen
weiterhin erwartet dass sie sich um ihre
Kinder oder um ihre Eltern kümmern und
dabei Vollzeit arbeiten also zwei
Vollzeitstellen besitzen aber sie
konkurrieren so automatisch mit Menschen
die nur eine Vollzeitstelle haben Frauen
die also beides machen konkurrieren mit
Leuten die nur eine dieser Tätigkeiten
ausüben
das ist als würde man ein Rennen laufen
und die Hälfte der Teilnehmer hat einen
Rucksack voller Steine auf den Rücken
und dann wundert man sich warum einige
langsamer ins Ziel kommen
wir müssen anerkennen dass Frauen hier
eine Sonderstellung besitzen Eltern
sollten die Zeit und den Raum haben sich
um ihre Kinder zu kümmern und
gleichzeitig zu arbeiten doch das
erfordert ein viel größeres umdenken
[Musik]
die Auswirkungen des gender-gaps sind in
der gesamten Weltwirtschaft zu
beobachten die Beschäftigungsquote von
Frauen im Erwerbstätigen Alter ist in
den Vereinigten Staaten seit fast zwei
Jahrzehnten rückläufig im Jahr 2014
waren nur 70% der Frauen zwischen 25 und
54 Jahren erwerbstätig
in dem skandinavischen Ländern ist diese
Zahl weitaus höher es ist nicht
verwunderlich dass der gender gap in
diesen Ländern am geringsten ist
es gibt Länder die bereits auf den Weg
zu einer echten Gleichstellung sind das
sind vor allem die nordischen Länder wie
Dänemark Schweden Finnland oder Norwegen
sie haben verstanden dass die Erziehung
von Kindern eine soziale und
wirtschaftliche Investition ist ihre
Regierungen wissen dass sie in
mutterschafts- und vaterschaftsurlaube
investieren müssen der
Vaterschaftsurlaub ist hier besonders
wichtig da er Anreize für Männer
schaffen soll nicht nur einen oder zwei
Monate sondern über die drei Monate
hinauszugehen
und das tun sie zum Teil indem sie einen
Monat oder manchmal zwei Monate als eine
Art
es wäre also völlig idiotisch diesen
Urlaub mit seinen Kindern nicht zu
nehmen und ihn dadurch verfallen zu
lassen das wäre gerade zu verrückt
wenn die Betreuung der Familie
aufgeteilt werden soll muss der Gender
gab überwunden werden das bedeutet auch
dass die traditionellen Rollen von Mann
und Frau der Vergangenheit angehören
man muss sich natürlich daran gewöhnen
dass auch Männer hauptbezugspersonen für
kleine Kinder sein können außerdem
müssen Männer begreifen dass sie hier
genauso wichtig sind wie wir Frauen in
vielerlei Hinsicht sogar noch wichtiger
oder zumindest gleich wichtig
der Chef eines großen finnischen
Unternehmens sagte zu mir wenn
heutzutage eine junger Mann zu mir kommt
und sagt er möchte seinen
Vaterschaftsurlaub nicht nehmen dann
frage ich mich ernsthaft was stimmt mit
ihm nicht und genau das ist der richtige
Ansatz
Skandinavien ist auf dem besten Weg
dorthin die nordischen Länder leisten
Pionierarbeit bei neuen Modellen für
Arbeit und Elternschaft und verringern
so dabei die Kluft zwischen den
Geschlechtern
[Musik]
überall auf der Welt erreichen Frauen
Spitzenpositionen in Wirtschaft und
Politik aber sie haben es schwer dort zu
bleiben
ich nenne mich selbst eine ungeduldige
Optimistin ungeduldig weil ich sehe wie
die Welt für Frauen immer besser wird
aber es geht mir nicht schnell genug wir
müssen noch viel tun um das weiter
voranzutreiben ich würde Ihnen gerne
sagen dass ich als weiblicher ciot die
Struktur der Diversität in meinem
eigenen Unternehmen verändert habe und
mit gutem Beispiel vorangehe aber in der
Realität sieht es leider so aus dass wir
in Bezug auf die Vertretung von Frauen
ein Problem haben
nach der Krise ist die Vielfalt an der
Wall Street sogar geringer als davor man
müsste meinen dass das Gegenteil der
Fall ist es ist auf der anderen Seite
nicht besser geworden und das kostet der
Wall Street eine Menge Geld
ist der Meinung dass der Erfolg der
skandinavischen Länder darauf
zurückzuführen ist wie Unternehmen und
Regierungen das Familienleben
integrieren das Konzept ist anders
Skandinavien ist weltweit führend bei
der Gleichstellung der Geschlechter doch
diese Erfolg ist hart erkämpft als ich
zwanzig war leistete ich meinen
Wehrdienst ab wir waren drei Frauen in
einer Gruppe von insgesamt 60 Personen
ich lief einen Halbmarathon mit 15 Kilo
auf dem Rücken und kam unter die ersten
Zehn alle meinten ich hätte Glück gehabt
und das sagten sie immer wieder wenn ich
zum Beispiel auf dem Schießstand war
oder als ich die Prüfungen Bestand meine
Leistung wurde einfach nicht so
gewürdigt wie die der Jungs
sophia hat es sich zur Aufgabe gemacht
diese Kultur zu hinterfragen
zu jedem gilt als eines der Länder mit
der fortschrittlichsten
Geschlechtergleichstellung der Welt und
das sind wir auch wenn man sich unsere
Gesetzgebung anschaut oder die Tatsache
dass man hier Familie und Beruf
vereinbaren kann dann sieht man dass wir
über dem EU-Durchschnitt liegen auch
wenn es um Frauen in der Arbeitswelt
geht schaut man aber in die
Führungspositionen sind wir immer noch
weit zurück und liegen hier sogar unter
den EU-Durchschnitt und der liegt glaube
ich bei 27% weiblicher Führungskräfte in
Schweden haben wir ungefähr 23%
[Musik]
Sophias Aufgabe ist es die gläserne
Decke in der schwedischen
Privatwirtschaft zu durchbrechen
wir arbeiten mit Unternehmen die vor ca
100 Jahren gegründet wurden als sie
begannen Personal einzustellen zu
kommunizieren Feedback zu geben oder mit
ihren Kunden zu interagieren taten sie
das auf eine ganz bestimmte Art und
Weise und das tun sie teilweise immer
noch aber die Welt hat sich verändert
die gläserne Decke ist also eine Art
veraltete kulturelle Norm man muss diese
Kultur ändern um die gläserne Decke zu
durchbrechen heute sind 80% der
weltweiten Konsumenten Frauen eine Menge
Kaufkraft und sie haben mehr Geld als
früher
64% der Hochschulabsolventen sind Frauen
die Zukunft gehört uns und wenn wir
nicht lernen damit umzugehen werden alle
verlieren
[Musik]
sich mit der Unternehmenskultur
durcheinandersetzt sind schwedische
Familien bereits auf einem guten Weg der
Gleichstellung zwischen Mann und Frau so
teilt sich Sophia die Betreuung ihrer
beiden Kinder sind gleichen Teile und
ihrem Mann Harry der ebenfalls eine
leitende Position hat
als CEO eines Unternehmens ist man daran
gewöhnt früh aufzustehen und hart zu
arbeiten aber ich kann mich auch von
fünf bis acht ganz auf meine Kinder
konzentrieren und für Sie da sein
wir haben mit dem splitting System noch
vor dem Kindergarten begonnen als die
Kinder noch ganz klein war für mich ist
das die perfekte Mischung ich habe einen
erfüllenden Job und kann mich ganz auf
meine Karriere konzentrieren habe aber
auch Zeit meine Kinder aufwachsen zu
sehen und mich mit ihnen zu beschäftigen
in den ganzen 40 Jahren die man sich um
seine Karriere kümmert sind die sechs
Monate die man zusammen mit seinen
Kindern verbringt die beste
Investitionen die man jemals tätigen
kann
diese Einstellung zur gemeinsamen
kindererziehung ist typisch für
Skandinavien die DC ist eines der
führenden
Telekommunikationsunternehmen Dänemarks
mit einem Umsatz von über 3,5 Milliarden
Dollar im Jahr das Unternehmen bietet
seinen fast 9000 Mitarbeitern einen
großzügigen Elternurlaub dafür TTC
Business und Familie gleichwertig sind
ich denke dass der Arbeitsmarkt in
Dänemark im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern
viel freier gestaltet ist wir setzen ein
hohes Maß an Eigenverantwortung für alle
unsere Mitarbeiter voraus sie sollen
sich frei in der Gestaltung ihres
Arbeitsumfelds fühlen und betrachten
unsere Mitarbeiter als ganzen Menschen
mit Familie und allem was dazu gehört
quasi 360 Grad
TTC zahlt Vätern während des vier
monatigen Vaterschaftsurlaubs 100% ihres
Gehalts wie auch Sophia in Schweden
versuchen Sie die Kultur von Arbeit und
Familie zu verändern im family rund 85%
der Belegschaften nimmt dieses Angebot
wahr TDC glaubt an eine glücklichere und
somit produktivere Belegschaft
zweites frei hat sich das positiv auf
die produkteität aller unserer
Mitarbeiter ausgewirkt das bedeutet auch
dass wir sehr attraktiv auf neue gut
ausgebildete Fachkräfte wirken da wir
ein ausgewogenes Verhältnis zwischen
privat und Berufsleben schaffen da bin
ich sicher
peter jesperson ist ein Veteran des
Vaterschaftsurlaubs er kann sich die
Erziehung der drei Kinder mit seiner
Frau Christine Teilen auch ihre Karriere
profitiert davon
Peter kann direkt nach der Geburt vier
Wochen bei mir zu Hause verbringen wenn
ich dann wieder anfange zu arbeiten
bleibt er für die ersten Monate zu Hause
bei den Kindern das ermöglicht mir mit
der Arbeit zu beginnen ohne irgendwelche
Pflichten zu Hause zu haben so kann ich
mich ganz auf die Arbeit konzentrieren
ich denke was Menschen in anderen
Ländern wo möglich vermissen oder wo sie
zu kurz kommen ist die familiäre Seite
both parents get to know that bei uns
lernen beide Elternteile ihre Kinder
kennen sie kennen ihre Vorlieben
erfahren wir sie sind
ich denke was das Arbeitsumfeld oder den
Arbeitsplatz angeht so gibt es
zahlreiche Studien die zeigen das
Gleichberechtigung bzw die
Gleichstellung von Frauen in Spitzen
oder Führungspositionen das Arbeitsleben
im allgemeinen fördert und die
Gesellschaft voranbringt es ist hoch die
Gleichstellung von Mann und Frau in
Skandinavien passiert nicht zufällig sie
ist das Ergebnis einer bewussten
langjährigen Strategie für unsere
Zukunft ist es von entscheidender
Bedeutung dass der gentle gab Teil des
Dialogs ist und das liegt daran dass
sich tatsächlich etwas ändert
Kluft zwischen den Geschlechtern wird
nicht einfach so verschwinden es ist
wichtig dass wir darüber reden
ich möchte dass meine Tochter in einer
Welt aufwächst in der sie alles sein
kann was sie will es geht darum Normen
zu brechen und es sowohl Männern als
auch Frauen zu ermöglichen sozusagen wie
sie sind
die Gleichstellung der Geschlechter ist
ein wichtiger Bestandteil der Förderung
und Nutzung menschlicher Talente jungen
wir brauchen alle Kenntnisse die wir
finden können um die großen Probleme
unserer Zeit zu lösen wir brauchen
Wirtschaftswachstum wir brauchen
Innovation und müssen nebenbei unseren
Planeten retten
wir brauchen so viel menschlichen
Einfallsreichtum Kreativität und
Intelligenz wie wir nur finden können
und die Hälfte dieser großartigen
Eigenschaften steckt in uns Frauen
[Musik]